hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to doom eternal it is
finally here I haven't been excited
about a game like this in a long long
time and I even had the great privilege
of playing the game about a month before
it came out but now we're going back to
the beginning
I love doom doom is a big part of my
life if you watched my doom 2016
playthrough you will know that doom is
very important to me just because it's
one of the first games I ever played if
not the first game I've ever played I'm
gonna go into this ultraviolence that's
what I was doing when I was playing it
before it seemed like a good level and
hopefully this time I'll actually learn
how to play the game and play it
appropriately and you guys get to join
me for the ride so far
[Music]
rip and tear our tilt is done
well okay then say no more my friend
whoever you are
[Applause]
[Music]
these range
we must pray now please pray that he is
watching
attempting to acquire the help recent
signal
nearly 60% of our planet has been
consumed by the invaders
you have the health reason signal locked
in
target is Mars the signal for my worry
diseases that they fear not man
[Music]
I
so ready for this I am so down for this
uh who you think you can hit me no way
oh my goodness they actually hit pretty
hard
okay can do thanks big big guy that is
Vega from the original oh hello how are
you
no thank you
okay so I am playing on an ultra
violence which means that I do need to
be at least somewhat attentive to the
game and what's going on here ah yes my
old friend my good good friend Oh
tutorial oh I can skip this I already
know how to play easy I love love love
the environment I love it's so gritty
it's so dark I love it so much what was
punch II oh my god it's just II okay
alright fair fair just eat
I also got to remember there's no
aim-down-sights
okay much like my boom 2016 playthrough
don't expect me to get all of the
secrets I definitely won't be able to do
that because number one I don't have the
attention span for it and number two I
don't have the patience for it number
three I love the sticky bombs sticky
bombs are a V bomb and I am all about
the bomb oh yeah give me the sticky
bombs oh my god yeah oh my god oh yeah
oh this is brutal hello my friends are
you doing hey good to see you oh I love
it
oh I love it oh hey how you doing whoa
ultraviolence indeed whoop oh yes please
baby tooth one oh I love it
Boosh goodbye oh my god I know they
expanded the number of glory kills in
this one so there is a wider variety oh
I am feeling this I am feeling it way
more than I was when I played it at the
preview oh I am feeling this oh I am
feeling it and I am loving it look I
don't think that you could do that to me
oh I am loving every second of this
it's so visceral it's so good that's the
thing I don't know if I orchestrated
that properly when I was playing just
the sheer feel of the game is immensely
good it is divine one might say
[Music]
whoo hey thanks man I'm just gonna
borrow this
straighten your crowd it's gonna just go
fix a little line on your crowd is a
little off there oh my goodness oh my
goodness oh my go that's all it took
come here you
hey come back Oh got you got him oh good
get all hell yeah oh yeah ever know if I
was supposed to be able to kill that guy
they don't seem to want to mess with me
the only intelligence demons I've come
across yet I let's do this I'm so ready
oh my God look at this crap look at this
what are you hello okay whoa whoa wait
that's a hand what the hell
what happened that's bonkers what
happened to this place oh my god those
demons holy crap yeah we how's that
standing how is that standing oh this is
so cool I'm a big fan a big big fan of
environmental storytelling I love a game
that can tell its story through the
world around you and this is telling a
horrible story of humans losing real bad
ooh what do we get
gonna have create this or do I get full
auto not that I want full auto I mean
sure I'll unlock it I don't know if I'm
gonna use it but I can have it
personally I think that uh press f2 swap
with mods got it personally I feel like
the sticky bomb is just the pristine
premier warrior in all situations I feel
like I could almost play through the
whole game with just a sticky bomb but I
know they don't want me to play it like
that left all the pull-up objectives and
dismiss got it boom baby man all these
tutorials sure would have been good to
know beforehand
hey come back hey hey bubble butt hey
come on what you doing
whoa whoa oh hey you fighting down there
why are you fighting well just let them
do their thing I'm enjoying the
atmosphere gosh so much detail Wow nice
nice Robo dick whoa what is that how did
it lose well I guess I saw the giant
demon that was walking around but haha
that thing's crazy
so humanity had these tools this whole
time and still lost s this doesn't bode
well for me oh wait no wait I'm gonna
kill everybody that's right I'm gonna
absolutely destroy no one is gonna
survive and I'm gonna devastate the
countryside with my immense power oh
yeah hey hey stop it
love it the shotgun just feels so
satisfying on the punches oh no it's a
breadcrumb trail oh I know this who are
you
yep easy weak point Iraq Neutron certain
demons have weak points that candy shop
for extra dims got it
I got new that already oh hey bud poink
oh it's gone what are you gonna do and
then I'm a switch
watch this oh yeah oh yeah that's how
you do it that's how you do the switches
properly oh yeah that's the good stuff
oh that is so satisfying it where are we
no no thank you you don't get to play
who you think you are who you think you
are from downtown
I'm I'm a kid in a candy shop right now
I'm having oh my god I forgot you can
string up stuff yeah you shouldn't
looked hey bud oh no you're dead oh yes
Pease see this is nice having an open
experience where I can kind of learn the
things my god I like the whole thing
where I can learn learn things as I go
that's awfully nice I can make it up
there there's got to be another way
around here yeah here is it OOP OOP oh
yes please yes please
okay weapon wheel press Q or mouse five
swap your weapons
you got a baby heavy cannon you know you
know I love it you know I'm all about it
you know I love it but I also love the
shotgun shotguns good it's just got some
oomph to it okay hello can i grab
there we go I'm guessing this way yeah
oh that way how am I supposed to be able
to get up there oh probably in the area
that I was just to get the thing that I
just got there's probably another way
out I'm an idiot all right cool ah yeah
yeah of course right here then I could
have seen easily hello map download okay
good Oh Oh what is that
Oh Oh mr. secret but that's all right
where is that one oh this is fun
yeah whatever all the music oh the music
I am going to spend so much time
listening to the soundtrack to this game
it is like the perfect workout music
whenever I needed to work out and I
needed to pick him up pick me up I would
listen to the first game soundtrack the
2016 1 for this one I can tell it's
gonna take it to another level if you
haven't seen the documentary where they
have a death metal chorus they literally
got like 20 death metal singers and they
just have them sing all in a choir style
do for one whoa sorry bud gone
goodbye oh yeah they definitely want you
to you know hey buddy
they want you to utilize the chainsaw a
lot just because it is the premier way
to get ammo what hi
was that the doctor from the first game
or was that someone else I don't know
what about over here
oh remaining human populations part two
oh I didn't even read these nearly 60%
of the planets been consumed by the
demons with the rate of expansion
increasing every day the majority of the
world population died in the first month
of the hel invasion following the
catastrophic failure virtually every
man-made system military response was
immediate but only marginally effective
that providing safe retreat to the
civilians with many fortified locations
cut off from outside communications
facing overwhelming opposition these
makeshift fortresses have gradually
fallen a growing number of demon
presence one after another large
portions of the air surface has been
coming uninhabitable with swarms of
demon scout and globe and most regions
suffering from an atmosphere that has
become infected and poisonous by process
of some a form of alien terraforming
weird so like hell is turning the earth
into a more hospitable place for itself
although several hundred thousands more
were safely evacuated out of orbit in
the mass exodus following the invasion
the expected odds of survival is
considered unlikely for many of these
lifeboats carrying cryogenically frozen
passengers religious iconography and
communes are now commonplace amongst
survivors with the collective perception
of events taking on a biblical nature
many seek authority from a higher power
to rationalize the sudden destruction of
their world believing these events
represent a form of divine punishment
now it's just the UAC being a bunch of
douches hell barges whoa
the top mighty thralls the help priests
oversaw the invasion of the mortal world
the thrall slave Titan of the underworld
carried the priests temples into the
wake of the battle providing the priest
with a vigil of Hell's advance from a
strategically impervious in placement
from their temple perch the priests
would emanate a powerful psionic
influence imposing greater coordination
among the chaotic forces of Hell and
increasing their battle effectiveness
the thrall possessing superior
resilience proved indestructible by
conventional weapons sorting all
attempts by a RC defensive forces only
by severing the priests psychokinetic
tethered it could the Titan be
neutralized an act that could only be
accomplished by an infiltration of the
temple itself I'm guessing that didn't
go so good oh that's a lot of enemies
that's a lot of enemies so I'm just
having fun reading these but uh I don't
need any tutorials and stuff like that
okay I'll try to read some of the Codex
is that more interest me as time goes on
oh hi I don't exactly know how what I
did all right let's keep moving who's
fighting out here huh who's being a
who's being a silly-billy huh one's a
little bit of a silly-billy shotgun in
their face huh oh man it looks like that
the people here the humans in this age
were technologically advanced but just
not enough to actually survive this
apocalypse and I guess with the
environments becoming all be modified so
that their people turn into zombies it's
definitely not ideal right I can do that
too all right
whoa it's one of the things I just read
about you it's like a Titan from 40k
almost literally walk climb oh I know
about wall climb oh let me make sure I
got what's up here first though oh oh
really that's not Klima below and
whatever let's keep on it buh incus
thank you
all right whoo hey hey it provided me a
way out here
how about have a bye bud hmm oh yeah
that's right I have another gun I forgot
I have a another gun
oh don't this [ __ ] huh oh god oh
god oh god
for the fireball from a wall oh this
thing is no joke oh did they beat this
up I swear when I was using this when I
was playing early this thing was not
nearly as beefy oh my goodness this
thing this thing shreds now oh this
thing tears it apart oh oh my hell are
you talking about
Wow a rap no John stop it oh [ __ ] hey
hey hey hey listen that's not cool I
don't have the resources to be able to
fight you I wasn't okay hang on hang on
I got I got like nothing I got I don't
think this chainsaw is gonna work on you
ah there we go
well listen hey listen buddy buddy
listen buddy that's that was uncool of
you to do that to me I would yes tip I
know I was just caught with my pants
down house didn't have any ammo couldn't
do the shotgun grenade trick wasn't
farming up enough resources I suppose oh
I should've chainsaw
that's right I need to chainsaw more
regularly I think you get chainsaw mo
over time so I just need to make sure I
always have it
and you guys just die already wolf here
you are
got him okay what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna switch where am I
whoa where am I
Oh baby before for home
ieave man those things suck
environmental damage is no joke all
right where am i where am i where am i
what am i doing what am i doing oh oh
that is unpleasant to look at that is
that is no good okay okay so I got I
don't have months for that precision
bold micro missiles uh I mean honestly
I'm guessing I would like to have some
kind of sniper fire for it that's
probably good especially because I have
such incredible aim and there's no way
that I would ever miss oh it's like
something out of dead space oh you
undulating ten ticular bastards oh no
that's no fun she'd be a farming thank
you for your contribution thank you very
much all right
yes please
yes grenade yes yes yes please
okay I know all about the cat go demon
weak point
I am so aware
alright Luke mist oh I'm in the wrong
thing oh yeah oh sorry I need to borrow
this thank you very much alright alright
alright alright sorry you missed me
sorry sorry guys listen I am too busy to
be bothered by the likes of you
whoa no thank you thank you what what I
do not have midair - I do not have that
yet oh where did you come from buddy oh
god they hurt so bad that guy is no joke
that guy is no joke
yeah that guy's absolutely no joke
especially with that stupid thing on
your head no no no no watch this Oh No
yeah I just got to remember what mod Wow
whoa whoa I just got to remember what
mod I have on at any given moment so
that I can be ready for what I need to
do we're deal what okay you need to calm
down
oh my goodness you I went hi got it you
are just so quick I do not like you
coming coming coming I'm coming
door hey there you go sleepy bye bye
time alright
whoa whoa hey hey hey none of that I
didn't know you could stab them through
with the chainsaw like ass word alright
moving on let's just keep going
uh-buh-buh-buh mm-hmm okay
thank you for your support during this
transition
your suffering continues to inspire us
I'm beginning to get the picture painted
that the UAC are kind of evil bastards
you know it's real subtle this
storytelling real real whoa hey bud nice
mountain and you're dead
sorry bud sorry bud climb aboard
oh that really that really looks Klima
below whatever all right t-then all
righty then whoop thank you thank you
wait I smell a secret somewhere here but
again I'm not persistent enough or
observant enough to get it why are they
all fighting each others I guess it's
hell so chaotic kind of like the forces
of chaos in 40k not to compare
everything to 40k but a little bit
formation of the whoa together we
survive interesting what is the air see
I don't think the air see with was a
thing in the first game following the
total collapse of international
civilization nations and boundaries as
we know them have ceased to exist a
handful of remaining bureaucrats
government officials and military
leavers have managed to survive by you
use of protective bunkers kept secret to
the greater population convenien under
the flag of the Allied nations this
governing body represents all that
remains of the rule of law forming what
would essentially become a single world
government military bases in
communication with the a.n have made
efforts to regroup and centralize their
areas of command establishing fortified
safe havens for survivors stockpiling
food and scavenging for supplies only
proprietary military use communications
remain functional enabling military
entities under command of the Allied
nations to coordinate in humanitarian
aid and defense operations by 21:51 the
formation of the AARC has taken highest
priority is considered to be in all
practical terms the last hope for
Humanity
yeah I guess having her to me whoa
hi I know about you I know all about you
oh sorry you done got sploded hello big
you all right
guess we're gonna go with the whole
floor but whole thing again I've seen
you many a time and many a game not
gonna surprise me this time damn sure do
love floor buttholes
oh hi where did you come from
maybe you should spit it out you know
you shouldn't just go swallowing
everything you see you know I gotta get
out of here
yeah too late buddy bloom Slayers here
God how scary must it be for these
demons how terrifying is just my pure
existence how pants filling lis awful is
is every last moment of suffering that
they hold dear all right never mind I'm
kind of getting hurt real bad
don't you dare he was about to he was
bout tonight you're getting Duns
Duns old I'm getting out of here I'm
going up get some high ground off
[Applause]
uh-huh oh that guy God get out of here
you suck so bad I didn't where am I
I'm up I got high ground good Florrick
you Oh
alright now that was a bug but I love
that bug that bugs great that bug of
suddenly glory killing to the for the
stairs above that saved my ass where am
i where am i oh no you don't know you
don't know you don't oh I don't know how
they did it but they made the gameplay
compared to the first game even more
fluid and I think that's like all
they're going for is like making the
most fluid visceral experience possible
it feels so good
that's the thing it feels so good doom
level - where's the doom level mean what
do you mean doom level is my doom Slayer
ranked up do I have more doom XP bug
wobb wobb wobb wobb I have no idea oh
wait I have an idea is that is it as
easy as that
is it this easy oh it's this easy
looks like I've got a big brain after
all looks like imma where the hell did
you oh god your head Oh your hand God
oh no all of you poor babies oh no oh no
oh no oh oh no oh no oh oh your oh
you're all dead
oh all of you oh no oh oh your friends
oh I'm coming for you I'm here
looks like you couldn't run away fast oh
hey I did it
hey bud I know you don't
got these guys love fighting don't they
well si signore Wow
God you suck oh my god you hurt so bad
holy crap am i falling into the abyss I
thought I was falling into the abyss
okay I got a watch because they're kind
of leading me on some of these fireballs
who should I kind of leading me around I
just don't need to be situationally
aware when they do such things because
that's how I get in trouble is by
allowing them to box me in allow me to
predict my movements I gotta say a
little more erratic it's okay it's all
good it's all good baby oh good there we
go
also probably mix up my weapons a bit
more sometimes it's not what the con
Mach good I love it Oh love it I love it
I love it I love it oh man oh wow
Wow oh they did not hold any punches
when it came to making the level design
brutal everything about this game is
metal as all hell I'm here for it hi how
you doing good to see you that looks
heavy oh you're tough though you're
pretty tough all right you guys have fun
what is this Los Angeles I can't tell
where are we I don't know whoa
don't mind if I do
okay
fast-travel you say fast travel you say
oh my so obviously I missed some secrets
but I'm not too concerned about him help
Rhys oh yeah who are these dudes what is
the deal here powerful practitioners of
arcane magics the priests have warped
their powers to suit their in city's
purpose harnessing the dark forces of
hellish psycho man see to prepare earth
for the final blood ritual by blood with
the help priests bound to the Dark
Ritual which now consumed earth and so
long as even one of them lives the
consumption of earth would continue
allowing hell unfettered rule of the
mortal world only by destroying the
priests can the blood ritual be stopped
and the earth saved well I think I
killed one of them this morning so this
game's gonna be over anything quick
there's really nothing to it alright as
much as I love listening to this choir
of the Damned I gotta figure something
out here okay
hi hello how you doing good see ya
are you are you referring to yourself in
third person
mr. e it was me you say I was the one
who was meant to restore its Oh
interesting
very interesting ooh all right so I miss
one codex I miss three toys I miss one
cheatcode ah XP gained what that what is
this season pass oh I'm a bum bum Sawyer
sick nice I don't know what I got sure
alright okay sure
I don't know what that's all about
playing the cheat cuts through mr.
Schlick does not disable progression
allowing you to use them can complete
all aspects of a mission
however slayer gates are disabled when
using cheat codes oh I don't want to use
cheat codes I like playing the game the
difficulty where it's at is good right
now
fortress of doom okay my celestial
locator
where the flame belch I know what the
flame does do oh hi oh my oh so this
what he does it lights people on fire
which for some reason he'll does not
like I don't know why oh all right fine
good it helps you get armor in the
middle of it which I imagines gonna help
me a lot when it comes down to getting
the flow of the game hello
Sentinel crystal tutorial this is the
Sentinel crystal selection screen
permanently upgrade your health and
armor oh don't mind if I do I think I
want to upgrade my armor first let's go
for this it's weird there's a there's a
lot of like upgrade system in this game
it's not everything that I would have
expected from doom but I mean I'm not
opposed to it definitely not opposed to
it just allows for a little more
customization when it comes down to the
game I wonder I got I can go through the
rest of the game the area just yet okay
cool alright there's a little secret in
this place that I want to show you but I
won't be able to get to it just yet I
got to play through a little bit more
but uh it's gonna be pretty sweet III
really want to emphasize the game is
just so smooth it's so tightly tuned
it's just you feel powerful but you
always feel on your toes which i think
is just really cool
so we're oh oh oh my okay so what's the
story here that's cool mountain that's a
cool whatever that is a gas giant what
is that so what's the story here did
this giant thing run out of power right
when it impaled this demon thing cuz I
was awfully inconvenient or convenient
considering it might have been the last
blow neat all right cool
good pardon the music kicked up a little
bit but I guess we're fine
nailed it huh sorry everybody
a little more panic a wolf are you doing
a little more panic than was necessary
[Music]
alright
oh I forgot I don't need to reload what
a fool I am oh yeah
hi this must be like my home world or
something like that these are my homies
except they're all dead Exodia
translation from the league roster
agenda book of kings
what Treasury comes from our darkest
selves driven by greed and want for I've
been deceived by the Digue
they came north with I the priests and
as our allies to our cause against the
con maker and her unscrupulous methods
their silvery tongues wagging they laid
a plan for us and sowed the seed of
desire for hasty triumph they claimed
knowledge of the makers source of power
in the demon realm a vast foundry of
souls where the innocent are put to the
fire for the essence in the foundries
destruction our victory is assured they
told us and the fools that we were that
I am believed our lies on their word we
sent the doom Slayer in the night
sentinels to destroy the foundry and
priests castigate for their regress as
the last veteran entered the demon's
empire our final
before claiming our domain the deed
closed the path and left them stranded
they were trapped lost in the eternal
void by the action of the traders how
could I not see their intentions am i
blinded by grief for the loss of
teresina bod of my people
we have fled again with barely a legion
of the night sentinels left to protect
us the décor gone returned to their
mistress may the race forgive my failure
okay sure
I don't know half of what that is but
I'm guessing hi welcome to the party
how are you doing see you around buddy
Oh nice jump didn't work out for you
this looks like something that I could
punch oh it was it was something that I
could punch hey don't jump over my crap
you dick
I burn baby burn
switch baby switch chop maybe chop
shoot maybe shoot yunk
done oh whoa wait wait what's it
stopping they're gone I'm a little
confused as to what just went on there
seemed like something wasn't adding up
proper frickin boom frickin kaboom Frick
fracking kaboom hey Wolfie yeah you're
doing tell me that's a whole body suit
that I can wear as a glove so I can
headbutt and punch as I'm killing
everything please tell me that I am now
wearing a giant glove on my head and
it's just poof doubles my height and
triples my fisting ability okay how Punk
blood the punch you say I know about the
Baudette event so I just gotta sing real
throaty style while a bunch of people I
can do that no problem think you're
doing hi Cooper 103 for one I'll take
that yes please
goodbye well goodbye
oh okay blood punch I need to be smart
about blood punch well that thing looks
like that con maker person methinks
there's something about this
technological thing might be might be
something about that ooh performing
glory kills faster well I wouldn't be
able to enjoy them launch into a glory
kill from much further away getting a
speed boost and that's good
survive one deathblow and briefly slow
time crease how long enemies remain
staggered greatly increased movement
control wall and air that's cool
never slow down time enemies killed by
blood punch shockwave drop health I
think the health one actually is
probably going to be the best I think
right that makes sense cuz that way if
I'm intelligent about blood punch yeah
yeah injected into me that can't be good
that can't be good
that way I would actually know what I'm
doing right or I would keep myself alive
a bit better if I did that hope thank
you
oh hi 1up alright was that a secret or
was that just there for me I'm guessing
that was just there for me alright
sounds good
can't wait to get to killing things
again Oh wha where do I go for the
killing thing Oh
literally the door immediately adjacent
to the place I was because again I'm an
idiot
what is that oh I know what that is
hope what
oh yes please baby what did I get
I get anything oh hey bud can you not be
an [ __ ]
yes I want this thank you
oh yes thank you that was it that's all
you got for me oh all right
pathetic pathetic if you ask me just
really pathetic oh I'm sorry I need ammo
you don't get to live when I am in need
of ammo I but oh what's that
you shouldn't have swallowed it no thank
you
hey is it in there
yo incus
hey where do you come from
point
god this feels vicious blood punch to
death point thank you
who's still will hey got your talk I got
your talk
oh no it's all gone oh no no oh oh no
you hey oh no oh you hate to see it oh
no oh you hate to see it oh no well made
that a damn shame you didn't survive
alright okay complete all encounters in
the mission to earn weapon points the
demonic corruption meter tracks the
points you've earned each mission as ten
weapon points total spend weapon points
in the arsenal tab in the dossier to
upgrade your weapon mods I like bigger
kaboom I like bigger boom if there's one
thing everyone knows about markiplier is
that Marky who loves him some big booms
I love love me some great big honking
kabooms alright let's see what we can do
with these big hefty heaving couple
wounds hello oh I didn't do that quite
right okay maybe I get air - somewhere
around here that person did not make it
off that cliff hope yo incus donkus got
it
god I wish I could just lunge it objects
that I'm angry at just out of midair
completely change up my momentum so lamb
and everything with my big meaty claws
that'd be nice
oink-cool oh yeah what do we have here
all this ancient priceless technology
punch oh man look at all this history of
my people that I cherish so much
incredible Biff oh no if only there was
a way to preserve our incredible history
our parents long history of the
Sentinels I I'm preserving the history
of my people by reading this very
important article codex Sentinel history
part 1 in the days before man's first
spoke an immense shard of rock and metal
I think all of the sentinels had a
Boston accent was cast under the world
from the heavens Thunder and Cataclysm
shook the land is the skies for torn
asunder the cosmic spear cleft a hole
through our mortal lands pull the pole
from the cold waste of the umbral plains
to the fetid swamps of iron fang the
womb of the world open to male amman
race the firstborn spilled forth they
took to the skies fierce tin their
emancipation and their exaltation they
brought vitality to the land and all
that felt their breath were awakened
from eternal slumber fierce beasts and
an unforgiving biosphere rose in the
passing of their shadow as the Wraith
call echoed across argent DeNooyer first
came the ancestral feral creatures
invigorated by the magic of the wraiths
they grew to enormous Heights mighty
behemoths who waged war with each other
for years untold the battles tore the
land asunder and destroyed all creation
caught in their wake
the Wraith call continued to spread
across the land and soon the Argenta
emerged from the steppes our soul
stirred into form but the power of their
breath the titans towered over the wild
blooded tribes but found them uncouth
the secret of the sword was discovered
and in the darkness of sweltering
Mountain forged as we beat steel and it
was strong enough to pierce bone and
sever flesh
thus we came to be born of rock and fire
lowly and birth but risen by the straw
of our will by the blessedness of the
first ones we Forge sword and shield and
took the hammer to the ancestress we
claimed the minion of creation by right
of blood and magic and the time of man
came to be with the ancestral beast
driven back to their bleak valleys we
rose we tilled the fertile land husband
did the beasts of burden and built
towering cities in the hallowed place on
the insidious Rhone we crowned king or
marrow the Father the first of the line
that shall reign in perpetuity
we built the Cathedral of reflection to
worship the first ones and formed the
order of the day whose priests pay
tribute to the race and appease their
tempestuous hunger our sons and
daughters chose the path of the sward of
the path the alchemists for each duty
honors the gods through our ways were
righteous we were not without strife
through our storms and great quakes cast
our spires down
barbaric tribes laid siege to our fields
in search of the great gifts mother
Argenta had bestowed upon our world and
the song of the wraith call threatened
to drive lesser men into madness
we were not lesser men we defended that
which the first ones gifted us our lands
and right to the bounty held within we
beat back the barbarian hordes and
hardened our resolve we rose above the
fire our bodies and souls tempered and
an unbreakable will was shaped in the
forge of battle what emerged was the
heart of our Legion the order of the
night sentinels cool man has got some
things I can punch Hey hey dude how you
doing bro buddy ah yes
of the - I was right okay I get it
oh ho ho hee oh hi thank you thank you
for your howls of approval oh I
all right
I know killed some demons killing dead
he liked my biceps cut holes in my armor
just to show them off wah wah and here I
go taking it man you know someone ought
to stop me I'm so crazy here I go mine
thank you the funny thing is I did our
loss despite their transgressions
against the government they are still of
central aha what you interfere with now
that you hmm
alright interesting is written it is
there are time to give manners if you
continue you will bring down the heavens
wrath huh funny okay they are no longer
your people for save
huh funny you're doing a lot of talking
and I've got a lot of demons to kill so
how about I do the demon killing and you
do the being dead thing that'd be great
King Novak who is this King no Vic sorry
ruled over Sentinel Prime for many years
as its warrior patriarch ordained
protector of the sovereign Sentinel
world's the Sentinel people defined by a
legacy of war deem only those of warrior
caste but fit to rule and in times of
battle is is expected that the king lead
from the battlefield rather than from
the safety of the throne as it is
written in Sentinel law a king unfit for
battle is likewise unfit to rule for
millennia the Sentinel people have
secured their civilization against the
threat of invasion from decent human
alike passing on the mantle of battle
disease about a generation and refining
after the war bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla this King is boring
and he sucks and he's dumb and also
stupid that I mentioned ugly y'all can
he do this though Oh didn't think so did
not think so
in fact I thought not thought big old
not on that one hello ah hi well you
look like you're ripping for a fight
thing is I've got big great big kabooms
and you've got great big nothing in your
face acceptance oh wait no you have
nothing on your face right good
you silly Billie's these silly Billy's
think that they honestly can possibly
stand up to me I love it I love it I hit
you I see that I hate you
oh no you're dead
oh they just fell over and died
what a bunch of baby woo why is that
what is it oh there's also a lore thing
ooh I want shiny oh I see what the lore
thing is well interesting that is
interesting the wolf's our gentle legend
speak of Sentinel be slow creatures and
limited companions are the HUD Wars
hoody so I've got a pet dog is what
you're saying
ooh grab it yes yes I did that okay what
about this over here I see something
going on over here oh there we go oh we
made it
oh hi hello how are you
secret encounters are optional timed
encounters hidden in the world any
resources spent in a secret encounter
will not be restored afterwards if you
run outta time and fail you can retry
okay oh hi Oh prop wrong one
I was ready I didn't I didn't think that
this was gonna be a thing I was doing it
Pat thank you I'll need this and thank
you whoa huh oh yes
all right out the back of the ass on the
greatest had ever lived I am the
greatest in the history of forever and
ever
oddly enough also and ever I'm the best
okay where am I going now what's do we
have here okay there was a 1-up over
there that I didn't get but that's okay
this is he could overhear that I didn't
get that's okay all this is in my book
wait how would the Frick do you get that
how do you get whoa what am I looking at
over there stand oh hi hey bud I don't
point got you take some flames that I
totally wasted on purpose and it wasn't
an accident that I accidentally did that
it was just a cool accent you know to be
talking about whatever I was talking
about so yeah that's what you get what
Alex fancy all right
okay I'm gonna go whoop it into whatever
this is we will don't mind if I do
oh that looks like it's gonna die all
right cool good yes yes please oh yes
wait what punch there we go that's what
I'm looking for
pop goes the revenant so it's shoulder
cannons oh no they're gone oh no and
there goes your head I love this plasma
cannon is beast oh sorry oh you wanted
to live I bet I bet I bet
can I have armor thank you
sorry
thank you
oh I forgot to have - now that's right I
need to start being smart I mean I was
being very dumb obviously before but I
need to start being smart immediately
now oh yeah where does this go huh
oh it loops loops that would have been
good to know in the battlefield when I
was in the middle of battle I wasn't
doing that who's shooting me someone's
shooting me oh oh hi
alright well that was good you almost
got me there you're very close real
close I was there by the skin of your
teeth but really really really close to
push the button this looks like a button
definitely looks like I don't want to go
into the butthole I don't want to go
into the throbbing pulsating butthole I
don't like the throbbing pulsating
butthole ah
why did demons like to make potholes
well my instincts are honed do a
cat-like reflex they stand no chance
against me right you'll never be able to
get me I can't jump in this you know Wow
oh I missed that one time okay fine
you'll never catch me off-guard
I've knew they were gonna put one in
front of this map but you cannot fool me
because I'm too smart too smart way too
smart
unbelievably too smart thank you oh oh
oh my oh my microwave beam caused them
to explode on - oh that's so cool that's
so brutal that's so brutal
oh yeah microwave oven yes I yes I
absolutely want to microwave my enemies
there was this weapon
what was it it was like it was Duke
Nukem like the original Duke Nukem there
was a weapon that would like it was like
a growth ray but eventually if you shot
one enemy enough it would like it would
get it would swell and then explode and
kid me was just like oh it suppose
vicious way to die you mean I get to
push the button oh you mean I get to
boost a bit oh you you're saying you're
saying I get to push the butt whoa oh
that's the objective
wait there's a secret sorry I got the
hiccups oh no guys oh this is good
oh god help there's a seeker here now
I've gotta find a way to get this a
secret it's gotta be down blow blow Oh
God
oh this is how I die Oh
am i sweating oh ah ha ha ha ha
oh I got an album oh nice
now give me something to microwave
please I need it desperately I've never
needed anything more in my life put it
in the thing fire iron man thank you
thank you very much thank you I do
appreciate that
Oh more law history the Sentinels part
do OK in the time of grief when King
Ettrick stook the throne a blessing came
to the people of our gentle white
porcelain beings from a world above our
own brought gifts of dinner service to
our great needs admirers of our
convictions they sought to make bond
with our swords and bring lasting order
to our world these beings were unlike
any we've seen before sword and shield
held no weight against them the ethereal
flesh of these luminous beings seemed
unbound by mortality able to move
through time and space they held sway
over all the minions of the known and
unknown dimensions through their ways we
grew stronger our society bolstered by
their infinite wisdom and all-knowing
power assuring our people's safety for
all time in this world and the next
where we sharpen the blade and mastered
our magic they bolstered the soul and
spirit death would no longer be the end
for our people
the ones we call the makers our new
allies in this brutal world have given
us the security and death we fought so
hard to achieve in life we would find
eternal peace and our minds would rest
easy with the knowledge that those we
fought alongside in battle would join us
in the lands beyond the mortal plane the
strength of our ways the purity of our
essence would by Maker law grant us
passage to the great city in the clouds
there are women and children warriors
and kin alike would welcome us we
adopted the holy doctrines of the makers
gifted in exchange with the chance to
earn eternal rest for our immortal souls
and blessed her dock the Covenant we
held now under the embrace of our new
God's foster the peace we had never
known for they were unlike the first
ones whose presence offered no paradise
from fear and the uncertainty of
existence in a harsh and unforgiving
world
the makers embrace was warm and guided
us into an era of spiritual prosperity
I'm sure that did not turn out for the
best in the long run I'm pretty sure
that's where things went horribly wrong
Yes No maybe so probably Oh what is this
oh this feels like a trap this feels
like I'm doing something bad here I go
we've what is this what is this hello I
see you nice anything else here probably
not all right listen learned unless I
learn where do I go Oh out
climb up hello sweet stuff here I go
that felt good I'm sure that was great
what I just did probably good
all right good
great even the best Wow
that is something Wow oh my oh my
goodness
hey buddy I hope you all come back here
way way way way way away buddy buddy oh
you know you don't need that yeah
oh it's gonna do nothing
oh no oh I'm sorry find your stupid face
ha ha look at your stupid face oh look
at your stupid I'm coming for you I'm
coming I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming
it led nah ah damn it
and you're dead oh hey bud oh no hit the
corn they're gone your guns
they're all gone hey but oh you are not
you are not chainsaw bobble I thought
you were gonna be Oh what an avalanche
of goodies thank you can I have you
thank you thank you very much oh yeah
this looks ripe for a blood punch baby
oh no wait something hit me hard
what hit me hard
whoa Oh Baxter life really probably this
guy was shooting me from above for
something like that something dumb you
know I thought I was gonna fall oh you
also god I got to pay attention for
these dudes
oh dude I did it I did it screw you
screw you're in your stupid face huh
come here you come here need to speak
with you about something yes please
thank you all right I want to melt
something you're getting melted yes
please love it so much I've never loved
anything more in my life I love it so
much I love it
all right cool that was great that was
great that was fantastic
that was wonderful that was truly
something special that was nice I am all
about that hi can you not have that
that's great thank you I'm gonna melt
you now oh no oh that's a tan pop goes
the weasel and you're dead
I think that's a trick lighting on fire
and then chainsawing is definitely a
viable strategy that is something that
is definitely gonna make sure that these
guys never get up in the morning also I
gotta remember to - Ashley yes please
I know I'm probably missing a ton of
secrets
definitely Oh mr. big guy are you gonna
go kaboom I really hope you do hi hi hey
bud hey thank you
hi goodbye
oh oh excuse me while I ride your shaft
sir
oh wait is this is this a scene I saw
from the beginning of this area this is
what I saw oh I missed that armor over
there but I know I need is fine
oh my goodness oh yes please oh yes
please
oh yes blaster beam Oh Oh No wait how
did it die before you stop moving hey
bud hey big things big trees big breeze
a big freshman dude big breach all right
you hear me a big breach okay cool see
you around bud
see you around kid zero oh no alien guts
oh god I'm gonna go out its butthole oh
no I am literally going out this thing's
pothole oh I made a joke about it being
pothole before oh how many things did
you eat it's an actual butthole oh
you're actually a creature that eats
people
oh god no
[Laughter]
no no miss sorry I my lightning reflexes
aren't what they used to be apparently
[Music]
hey bot oh I missed oh I can't jump oh I
forgot I can't jump woof
I can't - ah I can't - can't jump get
out of here we're mobile we're mobile
we're mobile no no no no no no no can
you be weak be weak please
I tried to get him before at Wow boom
thank you
all right whoo how many secrets have I
missed so far how many red it was on the
shaft that I missed what is that how do
you get there
wait uh where's like it was like some
kind of fast travel did I not what is
that yeah whatever you know I'm just
gonna keep moving forward hope for the
best
oh yeah this feels good
kaboom that's what you get hi bye
oh thanks
go on down need to go up there Oh point
I thought it was gonna be a thing
apparently not into the butthole uh huh
interesting
oh yeah now what did that do I'm not a
hundred percent exactly sure maybe it
allowed me to get up over there oh it
did ah I see
interesting interesting oh of course I
need to turn on all these giant robots
because for some reason they're all
defunct and I'm not able to use them
anymore Oh interesting
all right what are you gonna oh yeah
shoulder mounted cannon baby Oh shoulder
mounted cannon baby Oh blasted
oh please blast it oh please then thank
you awesome I can't believe these things
haven't rotted well I guess if you think
about it what bacteria would be able to
break down like demon guts that is a
strange concept there's something down
there
oh there is what are you there was
something that was gonna pull me in I
get more ammo and I get loot magnet I
love it oh no there's something behind
me help help I'm under attack the doom
Slayers being threatened help help where
are you oh really there's no more likely
story buddies likely story puddin skis
likely story war
I don't know how you climbed up there in
the first place to be able to discover
well you are gonna lose your gun
privilege sorry just had to happen oh I
love having more ammo this is nice right
in your big dumb face face from downtown
I did not make it downtown that didn't
make it come down down from downtown Oh
from downtown dead no you're supposed to
be dead
and there yo you're dead okay cool good
thank you for playing along thank you
you love to see it alright hi you want
to blow up now you get this so I'm
guessing these platforms fall down go
boom
ooh history of the Sentinels parts 3
with machine and enchantment of the
makers the argenta brought our newfound
clarity to the disparate elements of the
Imperium void we took flight with the
support of our God spreading the
enlightened word of the con maker we
discovered there was not one enemy but
many worlds and people's unknown to the
argenta were unveiled and we saw our own
suffering reflected in their eyes our
righteous Army strode in the battle
under the banner of the night sentinels
and fought for freedom of all peoples
from the grasp of those who would
exploit and prey upon them though we
battled on soil not our own the blood we
shed in foreign lands safeguarded argent
DeNooyer and the sun's and God has that
defended it through the strange peoples
we liberated new alliances were formed
and our beliefs became their own our
armies swelled as the Argento traversed
the Stars with gleaming war freak fleets
the Khan of the makers approached King
Rowan on his throne he sensed his God
Restless by her disquiet manner the king
and Khan spoke and the god revealed she
had foreseen a schism in the blood of
the argenta a test would be required to
identify its host among us she spoke of
a holy right to be performed on the
strongest of our warriors
only those that proved worthy would be
tested for the impurity could reside in
only the most resilient of our legion
the divinity machine a great tribute by
makers culeros would help us to cleanse
any impurities from our flock ensuring
our continued prosperity in this world
and in the maker realm that awaited in
the afterlife the malicious one if not
exhumed from our ranks would jeopardize
our safe passage to the heavenly realm
of our doc the Dark One was not amongst
them yet nor would he be from any
generations only the mother God through
divination and maker sight would
determine when he stood before them the
makers were truth and only their
unclouded eyes could find the one who
was marked the prophecy of the unholy
one was written but through the ages the
warning grew faint till only the Khan
maker herself in the high priests of the
ordered egg still whispered of he that
would one day come to threaten their way
of light am i that one is that me am I
the guy I think that sounds like me I'm
pretty sure that might be me now bye
guys I don't wanna don't wanna point
fingers [ __ ] I think that might be me a
high blood punch is there something down
here oh yes there is punch where am i
why am I here is that really it that all
I needed
f-fine whoop Adobe Hopi doobie where am
I going
whoa back up apparently I was gonna die
oh [ __ ] okay yeah Oh God
look ya'll got it hurts up I go alright
where is this what is this
Slayer gate optional intents and
counters ammos and extra lives will not
be restored afterwards
wha oh hi hi bud
you die now I'm sorry what was this oh
oh okay so I need to get a key so I can
open the gate is that what this is is
that what I'm doing
cuz I'll do it screw it I'll do it screw
it and screw you here I go
what you gonna do stop me now where are
we oh hi
ooh yes that's that's a key now that's a
key oh hell yeah make everything bigger
that's what I say huh I remember ripping
out a lot of hearts of these things when
I was in the first game oh oh oh my oh
my whoa
well [ __ ] sorry I messed up there
there's a lot of you ow
okay that just hurt me more than
anything okay all right I get it sorry
just took me a second I get it I get it
I get it it's a little bit of a little
bit of a dude ah nice nice and I said
there are so many of you oh my goodness
there are a lot of you that's okay
that's okay it's alright sorry I got
enough bullets for everybody they said
we'll wow there's so many of you okay
all right
yeah wait wait wait wait wait okay okay
all right here we go oh you look fun oh
you look very fun
I marry you I marry you what are you
gonna do blow up yep oh no a dreadknight
not very dreadful if you ask me hello oh
hi hey how you doing oh oh no you're
dead I do idea I wanted to talk to you
oh hi
ow oh my god who did that holy [ __ ] holy
crap who did that
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa my god who is
doing that
who is doing that oh my god who is doing
that to me who sent me that hard what
the revenant is it the revenant that
send me that hard I wouldn't have
thought so
and I gotta I gotta do a thing I'm gonna
melt you yeah yeah melt melt melt melt
melt melt do it do it do it do it do it
BAM
what no that was gonna be a melt giving
me a melt apocalypse
you're gonna melt you were gonna melt
baby you're gonna melt you're gonna Mel
Mel Mel Mel bout Cabo
bad oh my god so many of you okay I just
gotta stay on the move that's all I got
you oh man oh man there we go
give me give me give me give me give me
give me that okay good good good good
melt oh that's too much
Danny okay there we go
whoo whoo
[Applause]
Hey that was uh that was way more
intense than I thought it was gonna be
oh my oh in period keys acquire all six
man periods keys to activate the maker
device in the fortress of doom which
unlocks the unn maker yes please yes
please
yes pretty please okay so there's
something else that I missed over here
and then it looks like that and then the
red area and that's gonna be it for this
unfortunately that is all the time that
I have for this episode here but do not
worry this game is gonna be come in
almost every other day there's going to
be a new episode so I'm gonna try to do
this like with a one-day gap in between
because this game is fun this game is
pure fun the gameplay is so smooth it's
so challenging it's so fast-paced if
that's your style then damn go for it
I'm playing at a higher difficulty I'm
not doing the hardest but I'm doing
eltra violence just because like that's
what gives me a nice challenge like that
arena there that I'm still learning and
I'm still getting better at it but that
was a fun challenge like this game is
fun but if you can't handle that kind of
level there are still other difficulty
settings to do so don't be like scared
or intimidated to play this I imagine if
you're playing this on like hurt me
plenty you're still gonna have a great
time because you're gonna feel like a
tank just ripping through demons but I
can't wait to finish this game this game
is so fun I am tickled to death I enjoy
every second of it and frankly this is
just going to be it's gonna be so fun so
thank you everybody so much for watching
stay tuned for more episodes when they
come if you want to subscribe to know
when they're here and ring the bell to
get a notification please do that down
with the button right there if you want
to check out doom 2016 and my
playthrough of that back when I still
had red hair I believe it'll be linked
in the description below and maybe it'll
be in the suggestive videos down over
there
so thanks again everybody and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]